this Ashley Madison scandal continues to
grow you've heard about this yes it's
the it's the scandal it's the the dating
site for married cheaters and quite
famous and it was hacked and all all of
its 35 million private members were
revealed now yeah and it's very
embarrassing for them yeah and it's a
huge story well just before the show we
did a search of all of our studio
audience members email addresses we did
we did and the good news is none of you
are on Ashley Madison so congratulations
but a few of you are on some weird sites
that I'm guessing you want to keep
secret so we're going to show them on
the air right now
Rhys that's what we do better to get it
out in the open yeah then spend a
lifetime in hiding start the healing
start the healing now by exposing your
sickness who's our first victim right
now oh here he is
we discovered this person is registered
on the site preppie Vikings calm
[Music]
nice next we have this person who signed
up for shirtless pics of pierce brosnan
calm this guy was on white mr. keys calm
come on why level one agency this
person's a member of black magnum p.i is
done this guy here signed up for Waldo
seeking Waldo's
okay up next this guy's a member of time
traveling and Franklin's done this guy
here shops it clothes made from traffic
cones cop
next this guy's a member Hulk in the
streets flashing the sheets
[Applause]
and finally this person signed up it
looks just enough like Ben Affleck to be
Jennifer Garner's rebound
your secrets are out and you'll heal
more quickly hey thanks for watching be
sure to click subscribe to see even more
great cone and clips you may now return
to your pirated movies and creepy
Japanese pornography